aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est sur le
stand de nokia directement vos pas et
vous en congrès ce et je tiens dans ma
main le nouveau smartphone présenté par
nokia le 8810 4g qui est le petit frère
du numérique sans disque est sorti il ya
près très très très longtemps
là on est très clairement sur du revival
c'est le smartphone pour les puristes
pour ceux qui ont connu qui regardent et
qui sont intéressés c'est le smartphone
pourrait se retrouver dans matrix
or là il est couleur banane est
effectivement jouer la corde mais
néanmoins c'est le spectacle à
construire dans matrix
[Musique]
alors ne cherchez pas les dernières
innovations d'autres smartphones ce
qu'on apprenne un téléphone idiot vous
pouvez passer un coup de fil mais pas
que confère pas mal de choses ils se
connaissent bien évidemment à la 4g pour
l'ouvrir je vais vous dire la suite
après un échange de tirs un petit peu
vous l'ouvrez vous tirer ici hop il
souffre comme ça vous le mettez à
l'oreille comme les bons vieux
smartphones de l'époque c'est hyper
ergonomique j'ai plus l'habitude d'avoir
insulté devant la bouche c'est hyper
bizarre design très simple un trait
épuré effectivement itx à main dans la
main l'auriez pas de déverrouillage et
pas d'écran tactile il ya une caméra à
l'arrière il ya effectivement un petit
flash il ya un écran couleur vous avez
aussi le snake le jeu mythique des
années 2000 une bombe le smic et en
couleur elle est un peu ridicule est
venu dernière avec le nouveau 33 10 ce
qui est génial là tu sais vous pouvez
télécharger puis quelques applications
pouvez rajouter facebook vous pouvez
rajouter twitter quelques réseaux
sociaux alors il n'y a pas énormément de
d'applications vous pouvez mettre la bio
mais en tout cas ça fait vraiment la
faire et c'est vraiment super
intéressant moi personnellement je
trouve que pour 79 euros
ça serait con de se priver si vous
voulez pas un smartphone si vous voulez
pas un smartphone intelligent c'est un
smartphone idiot ça vous tente
celui là il a un look incroyable incurvé
comme ça c'est le téléphone banane il
est vraiment top
le cran est sympa pour après voilà on va
pas non plus chercher des choses de
dengue dedans vous pouvez passer des
coups de fil vous avez des sms vous avez
vos emails votre liste de contacts bien
évidemment votre horloge le snake de la
musique dedans bon froid pour ma
paroisse temps lui demander la lune
ça n'est pas stocké non plus énormément
de choses les photos c'est du petit
souvenir parce que la qualité allait pas
dingue mais bon c'est pas mal vincent
pas mal foutu
il ya même la radio fm autant dire que
là on est quand même sur un produit d'un
autre temps mais bon why not
c'est pas mal il ya une calculatrice si
vous voulez faire un petit calcul dessus
enregistré de la roja bon il ya quelques
petits jeux en plus ce qui est
complètement c'est l'autonomie 17 jours
en stand by et 9 jours en communication
donc si vous voulez vous amuser passé
neuf jours au téléphone avec quelqu'un
vous pouvez le faire dit cette source en
maille
c'est normal d'un côté parce que vous
n'avez pas utilisé à fond sur les
applications il va pas être énormément
énergie vent n'ont pas vous bouffer tout
votre batterie
c'est vrai que ça c'est super apprécié à
côte on a l'habitude dans le téléphone
qui des fois tiennent difficilement une
journée avec le nouveau nokia 8800 10,4
g il aura pas de souci il sera
disponible d'ici très très très peu de
temps et comme je vous le dis pour un
moins de 80 euros
fondamentalement c'est un produit qui
est hyper cool et puis je ne peux pas me
lasser de tout le temps être comme ça ça
ne vous rappelle vraiment des vieux
souvenirs
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que c'est un projet qui pourrait vous
intéresser le nokia 8800 10,4 g de 2018
est ce que vous aimez les produits nokia
nokia revient enfants si elles n'ont
qu'à 6 6l 33-10 semaine dernière le
nouveau 33 10 il ya celui ci cette année
plein de produits hyper cool est super
intéressant dites moi ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter
est ce que vous aimez ce design de ce
produit de la formule d'aniane
carrément changé dites moi ce que vous
en pensez marqué matos en commentaire
vous avez bien évidemment mais c'est des
jolies pousse à vous abonner comme
d'habitude parce que on a toujours parlé
plus de produits technologiques de
produits innovants des smartphones de
plein de choses
là on est au mobile world congress à
barcelone ya plein de trucs carrément
extraordinaire merci beaucoup n'oubliez
pas vous êtes au top on continue comme
ça et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]